this is a Fox News Alert north Korea has
just test-fired a new tactical guided
weapon it's according to the Associated
Press Kim jong-un is said to have
commented the Korean Central News Agency
says chairman Kim jong-un observed the
firing of the weapon by the Academy of
Defense Science the agency reporting
that Kim said the development of the
weapons system serves as an event of
very weighty significance in increasing
the combat power of the People's Army
the agency saying that Kim mounted an
observation post to learn about the
test-fire of this new type of tactical
guided weapon and also guide the test
firing of it the announcement came after
reports of new activity at the North
Korean missile research center all of
this coming on the backdrop of what has
been very active movements by North
Korean overall North Korea overall the
White House not commenting at this
moment on this new test firing we're
waiting for any comment from the
National Security Council or any
officials in the Trump administration